movies love to blow your mind should
they still be trying to though
[Music]
so this is gonna be a little bit of a
ramble and partly as I kind of talk
through and maybe trying to figure out
for myself what I think about this
because I find myself wondering more and
more lately should major movies
especially franchise movies be trying to
actively surprise us anymore now I want
to be very clear what I mean about this
I'm talking about twists or surprises
that are deliberately hidden from the
marketing that it's very clear from the
structure of the film this is meant to
be a big surprise I'm not talking about
meeting expectations and oh you must
give the fans what they want that's a
different conversation that's not what
I'm talking about now I'm talking about
the massive embargoes that Studios put
all these attempts to clamp down and not
spoil the big surprises that are in the
films that they're releasing should they
even still be bothering and as I say
that I'm gonna be asking that question
strictly from artistic perspective
because from a marketing perspective the
answer is yes it is very clear-cut yes
because making something a big surprise
means that you are having the both the
online especially a press and geek press
and in the case of a lot of these things
you know and the fan community
theorizing talking about it that is
keeping it in the conversations it keeps
people's minds on it that's higher
engagement more likely to see the movie
so from a business perspective they
should keep doing this and they will
never stop doing it for as long as it is
a good business thing to do and right
now it is I want to set that aside let's
take it as a given I am talking only
from the artistic side of things is it
worth it anymore
and part of what spawns that question is
just look at the last few years worth of
major surprises that franchises have
tried to spring on us look at the
repeated stumbles in them reversals and
what was even the plan in the first
place with someone like the character of
Ray in the new Star Wars movies go back
to Star Trek into darkness and what went
on with the character of Caan in that Oh
spoiler Kahn's in the book we all know
that now - stop picking on JJ Abrams for
a hot second take a look at the Bond
franchise inspector and what it tried to
pull off with Blofeld all of these
things seem to be very deliberately
structured from the initial thought of
the idea from a position of ooh this
will be a big secret and we're gonna
Surprise them we're gonna shock the heck
out of they'll never see this coming and
anytime you go in with that is your
intention you are almost always going to
foul up in some way because any good
twist should still be worth seeing in
the film even if you already know it and
that's actually part of the ongoing
conversation about spoilers in the first
place those who are not as uptight about
spoilers will sometimes argue well if
the movie or the show is any good then
it should still be enjoyable even if you
aren't surprised by it now that's true
spoiling stuff casually that's still
kind of a jerk thing to do that's part
of why you like this conversation is
easier for me to have now because I
think the spoiler window is up for all
the examples I'm gonna cite but that is
there's a validity to that the narrative
and the structure of the story should
not depend on the twist being a shock in
order to work that's not to say that the
narrative can't depend on the twist in
some way if you are integrating a twist
or reveal properly
then that should have an impact on the
story narrative in the direction but if
the enjoyment hinges only on the idea
that you didn't know coming in well then
it's not a good twist it can't it can't
truly get into your head and make you
rethink everything you just saw all I
can do is surprise you in the moment
because something like I have a tendency
out of the ones that I mentioned to be
the most annoyed at Spectre part of the
end use of the I said we were gonna set
the marketing side I said only and I
meant that only as far as the reason why
they keep doing this I got to bring the
marketing use of a conversation for part
of why especially with big franchise
films this is the bad thing for them to
keep doing so you look at a film like
Spectre going in
we knew Christoph Waltz was in it he was
clearly playing a villain they there
were pictures of him that had him in a
look that people were like is he Blofeld
he's probably gonna be Blofeld and the
studio's behind it did and this and they
really should have known better because
this had to happen previously with star
trek into darkness and they should have
learned then oh wait that didn't work
and there was a lot of bike back on this
but they made the exact same mistake
which it which was to publicly
repeatedly state he is not playing
Blofeld he's totally not he's playing
this character who's a totally new
character and in no way Blofeld and then
you go and watch the movie and it's
revealed halfway through that he's
Blofeld except that that reveal aside
from the fact that it's insulting
because we guessed your twist and then
you lied to us so that you could go who
did we blow your minds and we're sitting
there going no we figured that out and
which is another thing I'll come back to
that whole element but within the
structure of that film that reveal has
no meaning
at all Blofeld has not been planted as
something that was being built up -
neither Blofeld nor the reveal that he's
like James Bond's secret stepbrother or
whatever the hell it was it was really
stupid neither of those things had been
planted so they both came out of
absolutely nowhere
were they surprising yes but they were
stupid and honestly also had zero impact
on the story his plan in no way was
affected or hinged on these reveals
other than his motive to mess with James
Bond because he's always been mad at him
since they were kids which again is just
stupid but his butt and that's him
messing with the hero but his master
plan the thing that James Bond
ultimately has to stop him doing has
nothing to do with any of this so it's
absolutely stupid pointless has zero
impact on the story and it's insulting
thanks to the marketing and the
publicity push and it is very clear the
entire approach was we are going to
surprise the fans would Blofeld not
we're going to reintroduce Blofeld not
boy the fans sure would like LaFell is
like we're gonna surprise them and
coming in with that mentality I have
zero doubt was at the heart of every bad
decision that went on now I said we kind
of come back to the fact that pretty
much anybody looking at the trailers at
all figured out that twist that's the
back fire to that thing I mentioned at
the beginning which is ultimately the
reason they do all this which is to get
the fans and the press talking about it
theorizing and keeping it in the
conversation the problem is the more
fans talk about it the more they compare
notes the more that they bounce ideas
off each other the more likely it is
they're gonna figure it out so as this
sort of thing has become more integral
into the marketing and the publicity
push for some of these movies it makes
it more and more and more likely that
the fans are gonna guess which in and of
itself is not that bad a thing because
you know fans who are doing that kind of
theorize
probably will be happy either way and
that's part of the demographic where I
think it's gone it's safest to say even
spoiled they'll still enjoy it if it's
well done
and not to mention some people will be
very validated oh I figured it out on my
own that's so cool and that's fine but
here's the problem
that's fine in a bubble but you can tell
that some filmmakers and some TV writers
and some things along those lines have
started making their decisions trying to
frustrate that process so you have the
marketing for these things pushing the
mystery which just encourages people to
figure it out but then you have
filmmakers and showrunners who don't
want the fans to figure it out and want
to surprise them and then in some cases
changing what was originally planned
just so they can have it be a surprise
which undoes all the setup george RR
martin said this best because the
question came up about now that Game of
Thrones is done or at the time it was
nearing its end it hadn't finished yet
but he said this and now that all a lot
of the things that he was planning for
his books has happened now in the shows
is he going to change what his plans
were in order to keep it as a surprises
he said no no you can't do that because
and he made a comparison with a mystery
story if you set things up that the
butler did it
but then halfway through you realize
your audience has already figured it out
and just to surprise them you'd change
it to the chambermaid did it well that
doesn't work because the entire front
end was written on the premise of the
butler did it and that's what you were
building toward and then you change it
and suddenly the front end of the build
up doesn't go to where you ended up and
that's where we get quite possibly some
of the stuff that went on in the last
couple seasons of The Game of Thrones
show where they did not have the actual
text to pull from and you see interviews
with the wood Benioff and Weiss talking
about running
so and they talked so much about
audience expectations they were really
hung up on that or with Westworld if
they actually did rewrite things at one
point because the fan community guessed
a plan to twist so it's the it's the
escalation and the recursion of these
things feeding into each other that is
making it a problem in and of itself
having a twist as long as it's well
executed absolutely not a problem
hinting to your fans that oh there's
some kind of secret not that big a
problem that fan community theorizing
and possibly even figuring out that's
not really a problem unless you make it
one which is what's starting to happen
now
so it's each step gets a little bit more
problematic to the point that we are
getting things that has all this
build-up all this ooh
secrecy trying to keep things from it
which just makes people guess more
aggressively and more likely to figure
it out which makes directors and writers
go to more desperate lengths to try and
surprise us which makes for stupider and
less justified twists are there ways to
still do this correctly yes but it won't
really happen but that's to do it and
not talk about it the big problem here
is that thing that I said we had to take
is a given which is they will keep doing
this and pushing it as a marketing thing
because part of that beyond keeping
everything in the conversation if you're
telling people we have a big surprise
for you
theoretically it makes them more likely
to come out and see something in the
theater right away because they want to
see the surprise before it gets spoiled
that's also a big part of why studios
are very big on spoiler culture and
enforcing the idea of no spoilers
because they're terrified that if you
knew the spoilers you wouldn't come see
their films and they want a mystery and
a surprise so that they can chastise
credits critics who want to discuss the
spoiler because it affects their pain
the movie and to quiet down that
conversation so that it doesn't spoil
their audience so their audience still
come so the studios have this again
self-feeding need we need a mystery so
that they're interested in coming but we
can't have them talk about spoilers so
let's be sure that we're shaming any
professional who is talking about
spoilers during what we were considered
the window where you can't so that it
doesn't stymie the conversation and it's
just it's it's this policing of its
trick that's trying to control the
entire narrative of not only the film
that you've made but the marketing and
the critical cycle of it and there's
only so much control you can exert and
obviously they want as much control as
they can get
but the degrees that they're having to
go do to try and keep this cycle going I
don't know if it's worth it anymore
but I can look at something like say
endgame and this is not me trying to
aggrandize Disney and Marvel especially
when it comes to a marketing and
theatrical release business practices
Disney in particular is actually kind of
awful but specifically in terms of the
end result and the coming back to the
artistic element and the execution of
the product itself I can look at
something like endgame and the fact that
Thanos dies within like 10 minutes of
the movie and I didn't see that coming I
don't know anyone who saw that coming
and that could be considered a massive
massive twist but it's also something
that you never would have guessed given
the marketing there wasn't any publicity
around this idea of oh wait do you see
what we do with their nose specifically
they didn't build that up the way that
there was this built up mystery around
whatever the heck fake
name they gave benedict cumberbatch is
con for star trek into darkness or
Blofeld for spectre or ray for star wars
although ray is complicated because that
is made more difficult by the fact that
they very clearly didn't really have a
plan except to build mystery that was
the plan I don't feel like the decision
to kill thanos early in that film was
made because it would feed a marketing
cycle that feels like a decision that
was made so that they could tell a more
interesting story and that's the thing
surprises are good for marketing but if
you don't have one organically trying to
force one in or build a surprise around
a character that otherwise has no need
to have a twist you're just gonna end up
with something that is either clunky
painful or insulting surprises are great
but you can't force them those are my
thoughts on my rambling unstructured
thoughts on all this what do you think
whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down the comments and let's
talk about it there's the usual stuff to
do you know what it is like subscribe
share this around support me on patreon
maybe link in the description you can
click on it but you also don't have to
end of the day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]